epic primary battles unfolding across
america setting the stage for what's
sure to be a blockbuster midterm
election
it's still down to the wire in
pennsylvania where dave mccormick and
trump-backed dr mehmed oz are neck and
neck and only separated by just a few
thousand votes
but both candidates are confident of
victory
when all the votes are tallied i am
confident we will win
we are making a ferocious charge
but when is this close what else would
you expect everything about this
campaign has been tight we felt it on
the ground we knew
we knew it was working we knew our our
message we can see the path ahead
we can see victory ahead
and it was a big night for other
trump-backed candidates who won in their
races in pennsylvania and north carolina
which is a stark contrast to president
biden democratic candidates like john
fetterman and tim ryan have kept their
distance from the big guy and kellyanne
conway knows why
this is really reflection of what's
going on with the two political parties
and their heads right now so everybody
wants donald trump's endorsement that
does not happen on the democratic side
john fetterman the new democratic
nominee thank god he's recovered he
doesn't want joe biden joe biden went to
the state and and he was nowhere to be
found until the bridge collapsed and he
showed up in his shorts and sweatshirt
they don't want joe biden and kamala
harris campaigning with them and it
tells you the tale of the two parties
right now
that comes as mr unity goes negative a
new report claims president biden is
finally
going to try to stop working with the
gop and instead go on the attack as he
looks to create a contrast between his
job performance and
ultra mega candidates in his uh words
dana what was your reaction to what we
saw last night i think there's
oh wow how much time are you gonna give
me here all right well
a few things one uh if you look at a the
senate race in north carolina the trump
back candidate there ted bud ran away
with it i mean the cat ran away with a
spoon it was called at like 802 pm there
was just no question that that was going
to go in ted budd's way and mccrory just
fell away i mean it's like by 35 points
um
madison cother losing that is something
that's kind of you know this is a young
man who maybe he's we'll see where he is
in five years okay you know does he take
this experience and then decide to do
something different you know one of the
things he said is that he decided to
hire mostly communications people he
didn't need policy people well if you
don't have that you don't have victories
to run on our accomplishments to run on
and you end up basically running on a
message and he ended up getting
viciously attacked i'm not saying it
wasn't meritorious but so he's no longer
there but i think the pennsylvania race
is something that is just so interesting
one on the republican side but if i
could comment on the democrats real
quick so john fetterman also the cat ran
away of the spoon in that one he just
destroyed conor lamb conor lamb was a
guy who was considered like you would
think he was the perfect candidate
straight out of central casting for a
moderate democrat in a state like
pennsylvania where he could appeal to
the working class and he could also like
rub elbows with the
tech guys that want to build more
companies in pennsylvania and pittsburgh
and he just could never get any traction
why so john fetterman his lieutenant
governor he ends up in the hospital gets
has a stroke this guy though absolutely
destroyed conor lamb and so this tells
you where the democratic party is going
fetterman oozes charisma and
authenticity he is a original bernie bro
right he wants medicare for all
and he is going to be tagged as a
socialist but i'm telling you the
republicans should not sleep on him
because this race is also going to be
very tight it's not going to be tight in
north carolina but pennsylvania will
remain tight on the republican side of
things i would say that there's only one
candidate presidential candidate that
has won pennsylvania since 1990 1988 and
that was donald trump
and he ran a race that was
different
it was wild people
following it they he created this
amazing base of support
and any republican who is not him has to
run a near perfect race mitch mcconnell
day said he believes that whoever wins
in pennsylvania that they feel very
strongly that they can win in
pennsylvania but i will tell you i think
that the republicans are just make sure
that while they have this fight and they
might have a recount john fetterman's
campaign is already off
oh fetterman he's about your size i
think right no he's shorter but yeah six
nine yeah shorter yeah yeah uh and he's
smaller he doesn't like suits he wears
sweats yeah i get i like him and in the
sense he's different but
looking at what i saw was
a fever of just battles from top like
republicans had votes going three deep
which means the numbers when you look at
who was showing up to vote the numbers
of republicans that were coming out to
vote
i don't care if you're superman running
for a democrat you should really be
afraid because
yes your campaign's getting started
early but the sheer numbers third place
is running strong which means that when
all of them come together and they have
to come together and i think they will i
think the republicans get it they're you
know
they know they've seen what's going on
they want their police forces back they
want respect back they want to get
inflation down they want to get america
back at least in the top five of
importance in this country right now so
we're seeing big numbers and i'm just
looking at how many people are showing
up at the ballot and it's a huge
difference i think the only ones who are
showing up for the democrats are the
progressives yeah because
the moderates are going you know what
we're kind of better off for the other
guys that's a good point do you think
that the republicans are going to
coalesce around mimet or mccormick or
whoever it is i do absolutely and i
think that uh
john fetterman probably doesn't want to
go up against mehmet oz because not only
is he battle tested in a really tough
primary he's got name recognition and if
you're talking about socialized medicine
who better to dissect what the
government has done to ruin health care
in this country than a doctor who has
enriched himself in the free market not
only in medicine but in entertainment as
well so he really cares about that issue
and i hope he pins jon fetterman down on
this because with inflation where it's
at and you know taxes a tax hike on the
horizon you compound that with medicare
for all we cannot afford that uh the the
healthcare industry cannot afford that
so yes i do think it's going to be very
tough i thought the madison cawhorn
thing was interesting because he had
been pulling ahead and i thought that
perhaps the former president's
endorsement of him last minute might
help but he
so far lost only by a couple percentage
points and you're absolutely right there
has to be something there it has to be
substantive there has to be policy
behind the person
we can no longer become attached to
people because of their characteristics
or their interesting life stories how
they lead and how they fleece us far
more importantly
looking at the endorsements does
donald trump still have that magic touch
oh no no doubt about it i think that uh
the fact that
from my state in ohio everybody was uh
you know looking for donald trump to
endorse them and there's a very very
potent he had a couple of misses here
there uh we discussed car thorn and some
others but i i must say a couple of
quick points number one john petterman
is enormously charismatic he does remind
me a lot of you tyrus and i i believe
that he will cross over it's not just
progressive it's cool he's a very cool
guy i like him a lot i endorsed and if i
could endorse uh dr oz a longtime friend
of mine my wife lisa wonderful people
they're great on tv but more than that
they grew very good people and i was
very very disturbed by how he was slimed
by uh by dave mccory dave mccork was
also a very attractive guy he's a
uh self-made multi-millionaire is a
bronze star uh you know award of the
bronze star but uh going after mam at oz
uh a lot of it was muslim hate uh you
know uh the family born in uh you know
his parents were from turkey uh oz
served in the turkish army uh you know i
i really found that
extremely distasteful i felt very bad
that he had to endure and endure that uh
those uh those attacks very unfair
attacks but i i want to say one other
thing ballot elections when i was a kid
election day was a day
one day
you go to vote you go to vote most
people went in person to vote uh you
know
older disabled people and now i would
probably number among them uh got the
absentee ballots mail and ballots very
rare though as a percentage but
everybody showed up and then that night
you could gather around the tv and you
knew who won because the absentee
ballots the military ballots the
provisional ballots all these bouts work
where like florida does now after the uh
the disaster of the hanging chad now the
big you get the count they keep the
running tally of the people that vote
early and election day you you
do it not this uh this torture that
makes people lose faith in the system i
uh yeah i think they got and we get
better ratings when they announce it
exactly even when it's in the middle of
the night how exciting is that yeah stay
up watching not between 11 and 12.
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now